[Music]
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered i'm peter level
the ruling classes rarely agree on much
but not when it comes to china
it is agreed the us needs to somehow get
tough with beijing
what does that really mean engaging
china while trying to contain it
is that even possible the buy
administration will eventually have to
answer
this question
[Music]
to discuss these issues and more i'm
joined by my guest michael malouf in
washington he is a former pentagon
senior security policy analyst
in basking ridge we have james nolt he
is a professor of international
relations at new york
university and in beijing we cross go on
he is a news anchor
and host cgtn all right gentlemen
crosstalk rules in effect that means you
can jump at any time you want and i
always appreciate it
okay let's go to james first uh james
you know we we heard
when um secretary blinken was being
confirmed as secretary of state
he made some interesting comments
particularly when it comes to china
and he said basically he agreed with the
trump administration's approach to china
how do you take that on board and do you
see that
the the the biden administration will be
nuanced when it comes to china or this
will be a continuation of the four years
of the trump administration go ahead
james
one of my first rules about politics is
that words are cheap
and you can't always trust what people
say in a public forum to be
representative of their actual policy i
do think there'll be a significant
difference there have been a lot of
statements from the
incoming biden administration and i
think there'll be a significant
difference one of the things that biden
has made clear is that he plans to work
with america's allies more
and also follow more multilateral
approaches to china
which is different from what uh what
trump did trump was much more
into unilateral bullying and it didn't
work frankly it didn't work it didn't
get him results and
china itself counter-proposes with
essentially adherence to multilateral
rules
that is the wto and other kinds of
global rules so actually in some sense
china is speaking a better liberal gain
than the united states is in this case
because trump has been kind of a
nationalist bully
and previous american presidents have
typically been good at saying that well
we should have one set of rules that
applies to all countries
and the wto of course is the place where
most trade rules are enforced okay let's
let's go to beijing
what do you what do you think about that
and in looking at um uh the new
biden administration because um if
if tony blinken is to be believed and we
and
there's the assumption that trump trump
was a bit bombastic with china
how does beijing see that as a
continuation i mean because i think
james is absolutely right i mean
china russia other other great powers
have said why don't we just play by the
rules by international law
and it can it can relieve a lot of
tensions here go ahead my friend
well peter great to join you again and
your team
i think um biden's hands
would be tied he will have so many
domestic issues to
tackle his 1.9 trillion dollar rescue
package
will have a hard time to pass the senate
uh let's not forget there's such thing
as filibuster
and even if both parties uh kick-start
this
budget reconciliation process as far as
i know
the the republicans can still use voter
rama
uh to revise uh you know and then revise
again the
this biden bill for up to a thousand
times um
so we can expect another party in
fighting and there of course
is this issue of racism and the growing
division between the left and the right
and also the different factions within
the rights
of where let's keep it focused on china
here i mean
and then in the latter days of the of
the trump administration
senior level uh uh cabinet level
officials visited
taiwan okay i mean obviously china
doesn't like that okay i mean if we take
blinking it's worth
and i agree with james you know you can
talk trash all you want
nonetheless i mean if we're going to see
ambassador level
um uh um you know cabinet level
officials visiting taipei that's
something you're not good at
the government in beijing is not going
to be very happy about
i don't think let's face it i don't
think
trump got the issue of taiwan right i
don't think uh
[Music]
anthony blinken judging from his remarks
is getting the issue of taiwan right i
don't think the american public more
importantly got the issue of taiwan
right
i mean this is not an independent
country uh its own constitution said
republic of china
it was what the western society called
the free china versus the communist
china
back in the day and later on of course
there's the narrative has become
you know the democratic taiwan word
versus uh dictatorial um
cpc let's face it i don't think there
can be
a wise and reasonable u.s policy violent
policy towards
taiwan towards hong kong towards
xinjiang on human rights
if there is not anyone's uh sufficient
uh public understanding about this issue
well i'm afraid my friend
that that's adverse to what is what's
really going on in the public ma
you know uh michael you and i know barry
i mean in the first days of the
of the biden administration american
troops are moved out of iraq into syria
i mean one of the first foreign policy
moves they made
okay it didn't even really make the
headlines you had to really like go to
antiwar.com or something like that to
find that out
so i mean what i'm kind of beating
around the bush here
is that we're going to see a reset of
the obama administration with some
nuance
taken over from the trump administration
in the bible administration
michael yes i think uh you're right on
uh
biden of course was the vice president
during the obama administration
and it had a notorious history of
leading from behind
i think you're going to see the same
thing here again i think it's going to
be a
more of a a compassionate approach a
more compromising approach with china
trump of course was totally different he
as you say was bombastic
in order to basically leverage and get
attention and he did that quite
successfully
but the outcome of course was quite
miserable
and and as the consequence we had uh
two to two major powers here that we're
just going
uh bumping heads banging heads i think
that
uh biden will uh uh be much more a pr
uh he i think he's gonna show more of a
compassionate type of foreign policy
toward china even
and it will not he will not take serious
initiatives
he will be looking at
china more through the human rights
prism
and that's going to create instant
problems i think from china's
perspective they're basically saying
either lead follow or get out of the way
because we're coming we're doing our
thing
we want to abide by all the
international
regulations and rules along with
russia and if the united states thought
for one minute that they were going to
use
china to play off russia in this case
it's not going to happen
as we did during the cold war by the way
it's just not going to happen
and so i think things are going to
remain relatively stagnant
but china will march ahead through this
belt and road initiative even though
it's had some bumps and its recovery is
far far better than
what we will be able to muster within
the same time period
and i think that we're going to be
seeing a in china very very quickly
and we're seeing this effect now
having having a ripple effect even in
europe europe is going to
probably look more toward china and the
far east
than it has toward the united states we
already know that in the waning days of
the
of the trump administration the masses
and they don't see it but
it's going to be a long term thing yeah
but the the
the page has already been turned here i
think that american foreign policy is so
confusing
for an outsider that you better start
yeah you can
you have to start hedging your bets
right now yeah it's not only foreign
policy but they don't see markets in the
u.s any longer
europe is a is an exporting country and
they exporting countries and
and there we have italy already a member
of the belton road initiative
that's the beginning of the end the
southern part of the eu is going to
begin to drift over
and so i see this evolving uh and
probably accelerating
under the biden administration well
there's there's there's a lot of
kings in the road here because you know
i look at the foreign policy blobs
writing i mean you know semi-scholarly
no offense james here okay but i look at
some of the think tanks here
um i just have to wonder um where they
think the us really stands in the world
right now vis-a-vis china here
i mean there's james there's been so
much talk about containing
china you know in asia nato for example
like we've already heard you know
relying upon allies well allies in the
pacific
there's a number of countries that have
border disputes with china what in the
world should the united states get
involved with the border
dispute with china and the countries
around it but we here talk about that go
ahead james
yeah i mean i discount this idea of uh
an asian nato and part of the problem of
it is the two
leading american allies in east asia
which is south korea and japan
don't get along very well with each
other so i think they'd have a hard time
it's sort of like greece and turkey and
nato
you know they they have as much
disagreement with each other as they do
with china
and both of them also have very
substantial trade with china in fact
china is their
leading trading partners extremely
important trading partners so they can't
offend china
and they often disagree with each other
it would be very hard to have the same
kind of unity
that you had in most of nato in the east
asian region
so on the other hand i'd also agree that
the u.s really is not party to the uh
to the various disputes for example over
the south china sea the united states
has no claims in the south china sea
the argument that it's strategically
important is ridiculous it's
strategically important to chinese trade
it isn't to american trade
except for american trade with china so
uh and even there those
little islets are you know in wartime
they'd be extraordinarily vulnerable
they'd be
isolated and cut off from supply so i
don't really see them as strategically
important
what is important is the oil under the
south china sea and of course the fish
resources there now and
and understandably the neighboring
countries are going to contend over
those resources much of the way for
example
norway and britain contended over the
north sea oil until they agreed to a c
boundary yeah
but james but james if you know if you
take the um
the uh assumed or promised military
support from the united states off the
table
i would tend to think let me let's go to
beijing here now
and then then the neighbor would have to
rearrange itself
by itself without an outsider and
their their weapons of war i mean it
seems it means it seems to me
common sense that the neighborhood
should take care of itself
first and not invite outsiders go ahead
well i uh well i'm not a big fan
apparently of this asian nato concept uh
last time i checked most of the asean
countries uh treated more with china
than with the united states um you know
i studied international relations for my
master's uh
in america and most american professors
would tell you the greatness
of a comparative advantage of freight
trade of lowering
man-made barriers and quotas and
you know in many ways of course china
still have this market access issues
with some countries but
i think to a large extent china is
practicing what
these western elites were preaching have
been preaching over
the decades asian nato
i don't think it is materializing i look
at the philippines
there has been this good will civilian
goodwill between people to people
china japan uh you know hundreds of
millions
not hundreds millions but probably
millions of chinese travel to japan
every year
to buy products to travel there uh there
has been this good
asian neighborly relations between china
and other countries between
other asian neighbors i think at the end
of the day it is up to
these asian countries to us asians to
figure out
our own problems yeah but james we
we have to think of military budgets
there i mean no one wants to resolve
seriously very few people want to
resolve the the conflict on the korean
peninsula because everyone's making a
huge grift off it you know if it's not
broken why fix it go ahead
30 seconds before we go to the break
yeah that's why i study the business
roots of international relations because
i think business
understanding business is essential a
lot of things that are presented as
national security issues
are really about selling weapons and of
course there is big arms business there
particularly the more that china can be
the bogeyman in the region
you can uh induce the local countries to
feel they need to
uh arm and they have armed they've armed
very substantially although not all of
them by american arms vietnam for
example
still buys from russia and has recently
got the support or taiwan
okay huge arms deals all right gentlemen
i'm gonna jump in here we're gonna go to
a short break and after that short break
we'll continue our discussion on the
biden administration
and china stay with rt
let's go back to michael uh in
washington let's look at the really the
big picture or maybe the questions that
the obvious questions that are on
people's mind i'm i'm thinking of
michael right here
um you know this is just
china does not threaten the united
states militarily it doesn't
but china does threaten american
hegemony and
for 75 years the united states has
gotten use of its
hegemonic role in the world and it's
being challenged and it's not being
challenged militarily it's being
challenged in almost
every other respect and this is
something that washington elites
cannot stand and and uh you know i'm uh
i would even go as far as to say is that
this is not this cannot be comprehended
because of american exceptionalism
and that is the biggest barrier in
understanding the rise
of other great powers this is you know
since time immemorial right powers rise
and powers fall
okay but no one power is hegemonic
forever michael
no i agree with that and i think the
united states
still wants to uh it has actually
increased and
has shifted from the middle east uh
attention to
to the far east uh in the indo-pacific
uh region now
because it sees that that's where the
future of conflict is going to be
consequently it will be using that
freedom of navigation approach and hope
that they're going to be able to get
countries in the region including india
by the way
uh not only on the resource issue but
also in freedom of passage
but uh china is is uh
has limited force projection at the
moment
however however it will need to protect
its interests
as it expands the belton road initiative
into
africa into even latin america uh over
the years to come
and i would say that by 2050 not only
will be the top economic power but the
top military power in the world
and i think that this is what the united
states is grappling with because it's
still
holds on to that exceptionalism concept
and and and it also has still has
outstanding commitments not only to
south korea but to japan
and i think as as one of your guests
pointed out that even though
china even though korea and south korea
and japan don't are not getting along
these days
however they still have these
commitments to each other i think the
united states approach with them
would be more compartmented toward each
country and thereby
try to retain some semblance of hegemony
in that region as as a last resort
because
as you point out the united states
really has no
further compelling national security
interests
unless and until china does become a
world
military power and that's where things
will uh
become much more interesting yeah but
but if i could stay
with you it would depend on what its
aims and goals are
i mean everything we look at i mean i i
don't i i
i i would like someone to make the case
to me that
you know right now the rise of china
militarily is benign for the world
but what would event would happen where
it tip over it seems to me
in watching china china is not emerging
it's
re-emerging it's re-emerging from um the
the
the western including russian
colonialism of the 19th century
and it's i've been there i mean the
thing is i think the west doesn't get
that a non-western country can be
successful i i think it's just as simple
as that james is that fair
yeah during the 1980s i was teaching
courses about japan and in those days
the united states it was all the rage to
talk about the coming war with japan and
japan as the rising new superpower and
of course we saw that never happened
and i had i made fun of the idea in my
classes at the time because i said
you know japan had a major economic
bubble japan did not have military
aspirations to rival the united states
and so forth but of course
in terms of driving the budget at the
pentagon it was it was something that
was worth focusing on for the propaganda
value and i think china has much the
same role today
as you've said china's not a military
threat to the united states today the
united states has
overwhelming sea and air power it's
likely to remain that way for at least a
generation past 2050 it's hard to tell
and it would partly depend on whether
china feels they need military force but
what's very clear
is china is very successful in business
globally and so i think it's the
business rivalry that actually matters
and is the real substance behind
the arguments about national security
it's the fact that chinese telephone
service
and internet services are vastly cheaper
than americans and therefore the global
competitor
and washington knows that telecom
internet is the future
and if china's winning you know
influence and telecom internet around
the world
that's going to affect the cultural and
business environment of the 21st century
what happened in in in beijing how do
you feel about what james just said
there because
that's essentially my view because when
i look at american media
over the last 12 months i lost 18 months
it went from the ccp
okay and then it went from president xi
to the addicted to the dictator
uh the emperor she i mean you see this
change of rhetoric in the last 18 months
maybe longer
and and it seems to me that in it you
can't disconnect it from the economic
turn down
from the covid crisis here because you
know the
the united states you know if you look
at its its reaction to covet is
um it's not it's something you need any
american to be proud of right now
okay i mean it's just a mess all right
um
in ch in in in china i understand it is
uh on uh
on track economic activity is returned
growth is returned
um i live in russia here from
vladivostok all the way to kaliningrad
the reaction is exactly the same there
are no governors
you know um squabbling over this or
scoring points against this guy and this
person here
it's like there there is a uniform
medical system and
it's done the same way across you know
almost 12 uh
time zones here and i think this is just
what um the the media class
and and and others don't understand
about china that china has its own
aspirations
it doesn't want to export its ideology
it has no interest in that whatsoever
but this is what we're told because
where you were told this is the cold war
cold war 2.0
except for it's with china go ahead yeah
i mean china has been portrayed as
this aggressive power uh you know
a power hungry country that is aiming to
over
power and overtake the united states in
due time but uh
think about it uh has there any has
there
been another country that speaks chinese
mandarin as a
mother language i mean singapore is one
of them but it's a bilingual trilingual
society
uh the lingua franca of the world today
is english
and also uh if you look at china's
so-called issues with xinjiang tibet
hong kong taiwan there are mostly
uh you know historical issues um
your territories that has long
historical and cultural ties with china
that is currently
under chinese sovereignty um so
media coverage is not fair chomsky
famously said that anti-communism
has been this national level ideology
in america for 20 30 years in his book
manufacturing consent um i mean a lot of
things are lacking
you know the entrepreneurship of the
chinese society if you talk about the
business aspect
the meritocracy here in china if you
talk about how chinese leaders
leaders are selected we went through a
growing
college placement process pretty much
like those in russia
we study so hard maths physics science
in order to
to get ahead in society i mean you know
i i understand i understand within a
couple of years there'll be more
stem students students studying stem in
china
than the entire western world
it's about priorities isn't it it's
about priorities of what kind of society
you want to have keep going
yeah i mean you don't hear these things
uh in western societies
uh if there were to be a successful
country
on covet control it's uh you know south
korea is often cited
by mainstream media or singapore
um china was you know often mentioned
but in a negative light
in that they started this pandemic in
some ways
orlando exported this virus to damage
america
if you watch fox that's their narrative
um so many things are missing
um you know the rise of digital media
certainly gave rise to extreme views in
america
that only made um having a newest
understanding of china
ever more important i mean the thing is
let me go back to michael here is that
you know
basically i'll just go uh straight to
the point here
the the the sense of relative failure or
failings
is projected on someone else i mean
donald trump got elected because the
russians
did that no it's because you had a lot
of people that are disgruntled in the
country
okay and they wanted a change of path um
the the the the pandemic um has
ripped through the fabric of society
particularly in in uh in the middle of
america with small businesses be
destroyed somebody must be to blame oh
it must be the chinese i mean this is
this constant projection here
and it's so um it's not constructive and
it actually has
a potentially very negative outcomes go
ahead yeah and i think you're going to
see this with the biden administration i
think that they are
uh conflicted uh and and what has gone
unmentioned
is that both china russia iran they're
ultimately on a on a straightforward
path to develop
a multilateral world order as opposed to
the unipolar world order
that has been u.s led for years and
years and years
and that is a shift that we're beginning
to see europe has picked up on it as i
said
and we're going to see we're going to
see china pursuing that and that's
what's bothering the united states is
that they see
their their their own influence and
economic power and military power being
challenged
and uh quite successfully right now and
the recovery is going to take years in
the united states
because of the way we conduct ourselves
and as a consequence china is going to
emerge much more quickly
as a consequence you know and james i
know
you're familiar with the thucydides trap
how is this going to play out
with with with china because in simple
words or the thucydides trap is
there's a a a a a dominant power and
then there's a rising power and there's
three things you can do you can
give up and let the other one go you can
negotiate or you can fight
what how do you see that and within the
context of the biden administration
thucydides trap go ahead i've often uh
argued this point in part because it has
nothing to do with thucydides the cities
portrayed a civil war between contending
forces in the greek world between
democrats and old guards there was a
heavy
class component in thucydides which the
whole notion of the two cities trap is
okay you can be marvelous
that's wrong i get wonky on my program
but you don't get me here but you know
what i'm talking about
yeah but if you if you take the city's
misused name out of it um
then i do agree that uh there is
you know variety of approaches but i
think what's happening in the united
states and this part hasn't been
mentioned yet
is the vast majority of the leading
elements of american business
have already adapted to the rise of
china they've adapted to the buyers of
china by doing a vast amount of business
in china and continuing to expand there
and vote with their feet as in apple for
example opening a big plant
in uh in hunan and and now
the latest tesla opened a manufacturing
plant in shanghai
um citibank is expanding its business
including derivatives
uh i think no i think it's jp morgan
recently ordered open derivatives
trading in china
you know american business loves china
american government doesn't necessarily
but a large portion of america
you know why because the government
doesn't because then it
it finds someone it gets off the hook by
blaming someone else gentlemen that's
all the time we have here i want to
thank my
guests in washington basking rich and in
beijing and i want to thank our viewers
for watching us here at
see you next time and remember crosstalk
[Music]
rules